what's not like that but you can see now
this whole thing that we're seeing that
is dry land right now who are not here
then here you can see a forest and next
to a clear-cut four mile long they then
a lot of destruction in such a short
amount of time so it's kind of hard to
see you know she talked to one of her
heroes Paolo and Dario of Greenpeace and
he's somebody who's really devoted his
life to stop illegal deforestation Renee
was contacted by the producers of the
show I was thinking that this would be a
great opportunity to tell millions of
people the message that the Amazon is
under threat the Amazon is fundamental
for the entire earth population and we
all together need to stop the steps I
mean people need to know this I mean it
acts all of us you know
Dario it leads a small band of climbing
protectors he has more information and
more resources sometimes in the actual
government police is truly a hero as a
rainforest
if we don't combine alternative villages
with stuck in the first station the
global warming will be so big that by
2050 we will have no chance of stepping
back from you
Paulo temperatures all up to a dam
called Telus pedis you can see the
forest station around at the roads
development of dead trees
they caught the flow of the river so the
water array raised in that area became a
lake and then all these trees died
thousands millions I don't even know
like so much this is the last chance we
may be past the point of no return or we
may be right on that bubble we have to
act now it's very inspiring for me to
see those people who are so devoted
they're devoting their lives to
protecting something and taking care of
something that is vital for not just
their lives not just their children but
life on Earth that makes me feel like
you know how can I do more we can't let
them do that okay
you